[Music]
hello and welcome everyone to actin flab
live stream number 34.1
it's december 7th 2021.
welcome to actinflab
we are a participatory online lab that
is communicating learning and practicing
applied active inference you can find us
at some of the links
here on this page
this is a recorded and an archived live
stream so please provide us with
feedback so that we can improve on our
work
all backgrounds and perspectives are
welcome here and we'll be following good
video etiquette for live streams
all acting flap activities are
participatory so let us know if you want
to join in or co-organize we have
three organizational units education
communication and tools and weekly
meetings for each of those units a ton
of interesting projects to get involved
in
coda.io at activeinferencelab activelab
you'll find a searchable and sortable
site where you can learn more about the
past and upcoming live streams that we
have
today in acting stream number 34.1 we're
going to be learning and discussing
about this
fun paper the free energy principle it's
not about what it takes it's about what
took you there by actual constant in
and in
34.0
dean and i had a great time we talked
about the paper so check out the dot
zero
and of course read the paper if you want
to learn more
today in 34.1 we can go over some of the
key claims
we can look at some of the examples
again and differentiate the bayesian
approach versus the free energy approach
and just really take it anywhere that
people think is interesting so if you're
watching live
just
ask questions in the live chat and we'll
be keeping our eye on that and we will
just introduce ourselves go around and
then we'll
take it wherever we take it
so
we can introduce ourselves we can say hi
and say maybe something that was
exciting about the paper
that we remembered or something that
we'd like to reduce our uncertainty on
by the end of this discussion
so i'm daniel i'm a researcher in
california
and
i'm actually just looking forward to
seeing if anyone in the live chat has
some questions to ask because there's so
many cool adjacencies to this paper and
just the
beginnings of the thread were explored
by dean and i in the dot zero so
exploring the implications and what
people see as relevant in this paper i
think will be really exciting
and i will pass it to dean
thanks daniel i'm dean i'm calgary um
i'm just curious again to see how
as you start pulling on a thread
discovering how many things are actually
there as opposed to just the threads so
yeah i think today should be a pretty
interesting day and i'll pass it over to
david
i'm dave i'm
live north of manila
i did natural language processing with
big computers and
studied cybernetic learning theory and
i'm
excited that he's given us some simple
math actual axle constant is kind of
bringing it down to those of us who
stalled by the end of calculus one
just to sort of
lead-in question dave in the area of
cybernetics
is there any
analogous work anyone who said well it's
not really about being a cybernetic
system it's about how you came to be
that cybernetic system like are there
any parallels
in the cybernetics literature for the
kinds of things that are explored in
this paper
well there are yeah um in terms of um
[Music]
not so much necessarily the origins well
yes in cybernetic learning systems this
theory um a branch called
conversation theory
uh they completely cut loose the
notion of the physical embodiments of
systems from the
mimetic
or functional or conceptual or cognitive
aspects of systems in fact even types of
systems uh very much like what richard
dawkins did
30 plus years ago on separating
genetics from my medics which in his
case originally was just a proof of
principle not something he wanted to
pursue especially and it has been
pursued um in cybernetic learning theory
um the individual
is equated to the conversation
is equated with a s a type of system
that originates that persists
that merges into other systems
that may very well function through many
bodies
so you have distributed intelligence
right out of the gate
um
as well as internal differentiation
internal self-definition of each
individual as a conversation
so
definitely
the
there and there's a lot of math even
going way back to the 60s and 70s they
they
uh
there were cyberneticians who took
precise quantitative work very seriously
and dug down
uh very carefully on quantified
attention quantified uncertainty
resolution of uncertainty and the
qualitative
uh
consequences
of deciding
what's really happening what my plan
really is very much uh the sort of
fun
abrupt and
often irreversible changes that
uh
the world looked at in a lot of depth
when catastrophe theory burst upon the
world sudden catastrophic perhaps an
improvement but a catastrophic a
suddenly relatively irreversible change
um
[Music]
and here it is still working on it in
deeper and deeper in detail and wider
scope so good for mr dr cost
pretty
interesting it makes me think about like
a friendship
and how
maybe it's not just about
what the friendship is
or what it takes to have a friendship
but it's about the specific
conversations that take you there
so let's just kind of
look at the main
aims and claims and parts of the paper
and then either of you raise your hand
of course
maybe some others will join and anyone
in the live chat please just ask any
question or
make a comment we're just chilling
so the center
topic that's raised and it's a term
that's introduced in this paper
uh not the word but its usage in this
situation is the entailment problem
and just like the dog and the tail as
they say
the entailment problem is about
the relationship the
necessity and the sufficiency
relationship which ones following which
and under what situations they're
following each other
the entitlement problem is the confusion
in the entailment relation between free
energy minimization and life so
is free energy minimization
necessary for life is it sufficient
those are
the core pieces of the entailment
problem
and what happens in this paper
is a
simple dissolution through a trivial
toy
simplified example
of that entailment problem and we're
gonna probably walk through it again
today
but this numerical example which is very
stripped down it's not full active
there's no action in the loop it's just
a perceptive example
and it just shows that free energy
minimization does not always lead to the
correct choices
it's also conditional upon the priors
in other words how you got there it's
about what took you there because the
priors don't come from nowhere they come
from the past
so this kind of connects this
uh rigorous logic
within the action perception loop or in
this case just a simplified perception
loop to the
often ill or a logical way that things
happened to get the way they are so it's
going to be that
tension between
is this a rational analysis is it
locally rational maybe globally
irrational all those kinds of topics
come up and just to
skip to the final words of the paper
the claim
in this paper that's explored is that
free energy minimization is not
sufficient for life so not that fep has
nothing to say about life not that
actinf is irrelevant but that free
energy minimization is not sufficient it
turns out that it's necessary to be
doing something like free energy
minimization to persist in a dissipative
world but it's not sufficient it can't
be all that you have the wheels are
necessary for the car to go round and
round round and round but they're not
sufficient
and then that last sentence
the free energy principle is meant to
account for all kinds of systems
you the listener slash reader
the author of the paper
and the system of interest the organism
under study in a unifying fashion so we
should also explore like what is the
unifying
lens or what is the framing
under which
the research scholar and the person
who's just sort of like what is the free
energy principle and the bacterium and
what is that unifying principle and what
does the free energy principle have to
do with that
okay
so
dean where do you think we should jump
in or what would be um a fun question or
place to start here
well so i have
i have an interest
a little bit history with this so what
what took you there so if i'm meeting
somebody and they're an expert at
something i don't typically ask why are
you an expert because that's kind of
offensive but to ask what
what got you here what got you to the
place where you now
bear this title
the weight of that title isn't is an
interesting way of going about
trying to figure out
what
what logics they have applied in the
past
to
untangle problems and resolve things
that may be somebody
with less expertise
struggles with her or doesn't seem to be
able to overcome
so that's where this paper was really
helpful to me
instead of
why do i have to do this or why are you
such an expert
asking where did you come from
and then when being specific in terms of
so
how did you resolve something that i
still find
difficult to resolve like why do i have
to tie my shoes and then the expert says
well because you're going to trip over
your shoelace and fall down well i
haven't tripped over my shoelace instead
of going down that path
figuring it out in a slightly more
sophisticated way
cool thank you um i'm not gonna read
this blate quote but of course we have
to write it down
it makes me think about how why
which is an important question
often lends itself towards
generalization like why are you studying
machine learning well it's really
important and it's going to become
increasingly important and i wanted to
have a good job and other people told me
it was relevant it kind of generalizes
out
whereas what took you there is always
going to be a trajectory it's kind of a
path and that's where you get the answer
that's more like
well i met this mentor and then i was
curious about this specific topic and
then we did this program
so
what took you there is about the
specifics and
what
is broached in why questions is often
generalizations and we know that there's
not even a single answer to why like
we've talked about aristotle's whys and
about tin bergen why like why
is always going to be a plurality of
answers
whereas what took you there is going to
be a specific path and so that's the
tension
in living systems
is we want to understand something
general like surely there are some
generalizations we can make across
single-celled life or across mammals
but
also we're explaining specific systems
so
which
aspects are going to be generalizable
and which ones aren't and i think again
free energy principle as a theory of
everything
and something that does clearly make
generalizations across systems at least
apply to different systems
how does this
hyper
specific
trajectory based way of approaching
answering a question
relate to more of a mean field
approximation
averaged over
multiple categories
i think it's that tension that's really
interesting to describe so one is this
general versus specific tension
and then
if we can go to the simple point that's
made in the paper
that the free energy principle is not
concerned with the sufficient conditions
of existence but rather with what must
have been the case given that you exist
so this is related to necessity and
sufficiency which we talked about in the
dot zero they're similar words so we
should use them differently they're
different words
in other words it's about necessity but
not
necessarily sufficiency
and then it's not about what figuring
out what it takes to be alive it's about
figuring out what took you there
so
the title
is restated and turned around many many
different times because it is such a
distillable and simple yet important
concept and i think the piece that
i'd like to explore a little more is
really the pronoun use
i understand why the paper is written
from an i perspective because that's
convention with single author philosophy
papers
but
it's about figuring out what took you
there
so there's a sort of rhetorical element
of speaking to a reader which is
returning at the end of the paper those
last few lines about you me and the
system under study
but then also it's almost like
about how the free energy principle
is about systems looking at their own
timeline and trajectory
and perhaps not as much as looking out
so i'm curious about what does that
relational
element
mean here with the person relating to
their past and
us as systems relating to other systems
dean
yeah so the necessity might be you show
up
you attend in order for
things to
sort of continue on but the sufficiency
part is how available you are so you can
show up and turn all your senses off you
can be present but not necessarily
be taking in anything
or at least trying to actively avoid
taking information in and so
that's the part again i would agree with
you that's the part i found really
interesting because
to to not understand or appreciate that
there's a difference between what is
necessary
i'm i'm here i'm in part of this live
stream now but then i could be
distracted in all different directions
not really be able to be available
to what
is going on around me is is a whole
different matter and i think that's what
axel has done a really good job of
bringing it down to that personal level
sufficiency
has to be exhaustive
to say what's truly sufficient for the
bacteria to live
it it's going to include things like
well you need the laws of physics and
you need gravity and you need um just
everything it's like really you're
giving
almost a bit by bit play-by-play
so sufficiency
it requires an exhaustive account
because if you're missing something
that's necessary
you didn't capture what was sufficient
necessity allows us to just focus on
some aspect that we know is relevant
and then talk about
the why and the what and the how of
necessity
while acknowledging that we're just
focusing on one piece like that
one line in that one kandinsky painting
it's necessary for my interpretation of
it
it's not sufficient because the
sufficiency of the interpretation of art
would just send you off into the whole
universe maybe you need all of human
cultural history including from cultures
that you wouldn't even directly
acknowledge
for the sufficiency
to be
garnered in that interpretive setting
but necessity is a lot easier to point
your finger to
that relates to what
um
are distinguished as the strong and the
weak
responses to the entailment problem
so let's look over at this and again
anyone with any kind of a question
please just ask it because we're
chilling and
looking forward to your questions
so this is where in the paper the
entailment problem is
specified arguments in the literature on
the free energy principle give the
impression that in order to be alive
to count as a living system one must
minimize free energy
and so
there's a few ways to think about this
relationship between minimizing free
energy and life
sorry if you thought it was going to be
a discussion on a different topic
because that's what this paper is about
and it just again it's so simple it's
like
a shape in your hand you're turning it
over the shape is simple in some ways
but then the implications of the shape
and the way it gets
connected to other ideas is really
critical
and
actual distinguishes two
ways to talk about the relationship the
strong and the weak
and as we'll see
they differ not just in their strength
but also
essentially in the direction which the
arrow is pointing
so it's kind of like it's not like
there's a a little mountain in a big
mountain but the arrow of elevation is
pointing the same way there's something
a little bit different happening
the strong
claim
in response to the entailment problem
is that minimizing free energy is a
sufficient condition for life and that's
also called in some earlier work the
overly generous claim which is kind of a
framing that already says that it's
probably
uh
too generous it's it's incorrect in that
way
and the strong claim is the sufficiency
claim
minimizing free energy that's all you
need it's sufficient to minimize free
energy to be a living system
the implication of the strong claim
would be that all we need to do is have
that free energy thermometer and then
we can determine who's minimizing free
energy we have our meter stick on this
left side and then
that would be sufficient to talk about
what systems were alive or not
in contrast the weak claim
is a necessity claim
if a system is currently alive it means
that it has minimized its free energy
and such a type of claim does not assume
the fep is designed to set the bar for
the sufficient conditions of life or
meant to predict what things may or may
not be alive
rather it limits the scope of the
application of the principle to beings
that we think are alive now
and enables us to know the necessary
conditions under which those beings can
be living i.e can actively resist the
loss
of structural integrity what took them
there
so
there's a few interesting pieces just
they differ in strength these two
responses or claims that are
generated by the entailment problem
i wonder what is the scope of the fep
and is it for systems that we have a
priori
decided are already alive
are
non-living systems under the scope of
the fep
so maybe we can try to like do some
duplicate the slide and do a little
diagramming and venn diagrams on
what
does the minimizing free energy
circle look like with respect to the
life circle and then what is life if we
don't have the thermometer over here on
the left side
so can i ask a question daniel
would it
would it be going too far off the rails
if i
if i wondered
to take this idea
and say okay so i want to build up i'm
i'm
i'm an academic or i'm a trainer and i
want to
i want to build out a curriculum
knowing this
what does that imply in terms of
well i know what's the difference
between something that's
surprising removal because i remember
i'm the one that already knows this and
i'm trying to pass this along to
somebody who doesn't know it so it's
i'm i'm trying to guess what surprisal
removal
or minimization means to them i'm
supposed to be guessing what life means
to them i'm supposed to be knowing what
is necessary what absolutely they must
know and what will be sufficient so in
that context
how would we um
[Music]
how would we order this
let's kind of lay out a few options
okay so we have um
behind the first door
we'll use letters to talk about them so
we'll have
i'll take the cash monty are you sure i
can reveal that one of the doors has
nothing behind it
okay so we're gonna have scenario a
which is
their um
r systems that are minimizing free
energy
so they're systems outside of that
circle so there may be systems that are
not minimizing free energy
but within the set
of living things
all of them are minimizing free energy
so let's think about what kind of world
that is
okay
so then we can have scenario b
where
there's living systems
there's non-living systems as well so we
could ask what puts us in one category
living or non-living but
there's living systems that are
minimizing free energy and there's ones
that are not i think we can say that
because
if we go with the weak claim
then
it's fair to say
that b is
ruled out
because this would say that there's
living systems that are not minimizing
free energy
so we can say like basically
weak claim
uh
uh disreputes
this area
the area of that crescent moon
that's being um sort of
invicted against
uh is distributes a word
disputes we'll go with that
the weak claim disputes this area of the
crescent it's saying well all living
systems have to be minimizing free
energy it's a necessity but it's not
sufficiency
so
then a third scenario
would be
like they're the exact same thing
so well
that would be sort of a
well you could have minimizing free
energy is a sufficient condition for
life
so that means that the life circle
is
we'll have to we can't show total
overlap but
the life circle
everything that's minimizing free energy
is alive
so here in a
there are free energy minimizing systems
that aren't alive
like a ball falling off of a cliff might
be minimizing its free energy just like
it's minimizing its potential energy or
a burning candle might be minimizing
free energy
but
it doesn't have to be alive so that's
these are free energy minimizing systems
in the crescent of a
that are not alive
in c
we have this
perfect relationship between the two
things
and that is a very strong claim which is
that if it's minimizing free energy
that's sufficient
for being alive
and if it's not minimizing free energy
it's not alive
so
this is sort of the the weakest claim is
on the left side
doesn't mean it's useless doesn't mean
it's inadequate but this is the weakest
claim this is the necessity claim
then we have the strong claim
here
uh
that
minimizing free energy is sufficient
well
this is
this is the strongest claim in c
that minimizing free energy is
sufficient for life
so anything that
you know if
doing x is sufficient for
greetings blue
hello
cool light
we're um in the slides on 24 just
talking about necessity and sufficiency
c is the strongest case
it's saying it's sufficient
and so you're either going to be
minimizing free energy and therefore
sufficient to be called alive
or you're doing neither
and then b is a little bit of a middle
case that's saying there's some living
systems that are not minimizing they're
free energy but some are
so these are three now are there other
possible layouts and then dean let's
return to your question about like
educating and how do we think about this
how do we distinguish these scenarios in
an education context
or welcome blue if you would like to
say hello or just what
makes you excited for this paper
um i loved this paper i thought it was
great um and i have been listening along
in the live stream so i'm kind of up to
speed with where you guys are and what
you were talking about but um
i yeah enjoyed axel's writing and um
i like like the fact that
i can
implement the free energy without having
to ascribe to pan psychism and also
without having to ascribe to the mind
life continuity hypothesis or all of
these things that we've been discussing
um like the necessity sufficiency
it's there like
i think that axel sets out a really
logical argument or a set of arguments
um
and
doesn't make any claims
that aren't um
justifiable with maths
yes
using a simple mathematical example
um we'll we'll keep this slide around
because we can wonder maybe is there
some well
another relationship that we could
speculate would be like
a kind of
something like this
like
life
there's systems that are minimizing free
energy or not
and then
there's systems that are alive or not
and sometimes they overlap but they
don't have to overlap but there's some
special living systems that are doing it
and there's some that aren't and there's
some that are neither so this is the
most
uh we'll just call this one
situation d
d is the most
is the most
flexible
scenario
because you could have
a or b i mean well i won't use those
letters you could have life free energy
minimizing
both or neither so d is the most
flexible case
c is the most restrictive case
and then we have two possible nesting
relationships where one is nested inside
of the other
and
it's kind of
interesting to wonder what kind of world
do each of these exist in
um well where is the mind bubble
yes let's
should be around the whole slide is it
is that the mind the the modeler is that
why there's that relational or
personal framing of the paper because
the mind is the
mapping
of
these different venn diagrams dean
and i think it's really interesting too
daniel that in real time
we now have a slide 23 and now a new
slide 24
and although the we now know the order
that they
they presented themselves to us as
could we have started with 24 and worked
our way back to 23.
that's that's when it gets really kind
of weird and twisted but
it's also what i think the paper is
speaking to if we're actually thinking
about this and as a as another example
of a post potentially post diction way
of viewing things historically now
yes so
um
23 which now has a little
logo on it for those who don't have the
slide deck at hand
23 was derived heavily from the paper
right it was quotes from the paper and
then just a visual representation now
that was not in the paper but it could
have been interesting
and then that's right through
the specifics of who joined when and
what we were thinking about when that's
what led to 24 but
maybe we'll add another slide before 23
and then they'll both be a different
number
but
it does
bring up an interesting question
i think we could
look at well first dave thanks for
writing in the chat do you want to read
what you wrote or would you like me to
read what you have in the youtube live
chat
yeah um could i expand on it just
slightly please what i would have posted
if i didn't have the big limit
title necessary versus sufficient
two of the original concepts of general
systems theory have recently as of 1975
been resuscitated there's an admirable
discussion by russell akov
the first of the two concepts is that
whereas causal argument considers
necessary and sufficient or double
implication conditions
systematic theory or cyber systems
theory or cybernetic argument deals
primarily with a logic of necessary
conditions
see fred singer's discussion of the
producer
and product relations
and in summerhof this is called goal
relations
and i'd add
this deals with intentional action where
there are goals
uh
there's an old painful discussion going
back to
way before darwin that the world exists
only as push
galileo wanted to absolutely banish
goals of any kind any value had to be
absolutely
driven from science
if you say for the purpose of is get out
you're not a scientist
uh i continue
this notion underlies the more
sophisticated treatment of goals and
intentions conceivably partly specified
intentions
fuzzy goals goals with
um ill-defined uh
criteria which you might or might not be
aware of i would
the other concept of about the same
importance is the presupposition of a
systematic universe there is a tacit
assumption that things objects and other
elementary entities are interdependent
rather than being isolated units which
is the assumption behind the majority of
sciences
further as a result of their
interdependence or with the same meaning
of the supposition that things objects
and so on are not really unitary
these entities form systems and it is
systems which may be observed and
manipulated
so the notion that there's one and only
one way to approach an argument one and
only one order among
real things that are scientifically
respectable utterly wrong
utterly wrong if you can't work your
argument in at least two different
directions you haven't thought about
what your argument is
you don't know the boundaries you don't
know what it is
you don't know what a jellyfish is
you think you know what a jellyfish is
but you don't know the difference
between the inside and the outside you
may end up in the inside
so it's almost like if there's only one
way
to run through the argument that's when
necessity and sufficiency are easily
confused so if somebody just
drives in one lane from the beginning to
the end and i made my case
and that's all i have to say
well then
you've
implicitly through your actions your
enacted behavior you've uh
acted consistently as if what you had to
say was sufficient for making your case
the prosecution rests
and also it was necessary you think i've
included everything necessary and
sufficient so that's actually where you
get and here's maybe where we should
duplicate the slide again
you get that's an overlap of necessity
and sufficiency but then
if you did two
parallel arguments just you did one from
start to finish and the other one from
start to finish
now you could say
well
both of them
are
in their own timeline they were both
necessary even if they have totally
disjoint information that was being used
and then what is the relationship of the
goals
there and that
is kind of like dean's multiple eyes
open giving us the perspective to look
at goals
when we have multiple realizations
because it does help us distinguish
necessity and sufficiency because we
literally see
well it could have been done a different
way
so it being done in way one
can't be the whole story because we just
saw it what done in way two
dean
i'm sorry dad
you dropped off on me for a second there
but
so i wanted to ask david a question
about
yeah dean kind of drops in and out
he was giving some funny descriptors of
his internet hardware earlier it was
pretty funny
start again
sorry um so i agree with with what david
was saying and there's a there's a book
called the origins of order project and
system
and what the author basically says is
that projects are easy to
get trapped in goal directed behavior
whereas where if you
can also hold up the system
you can see
the number the sort of the multitudes of
different directions all at once and so
i was wondering
is is that
does that sort of fit in with what david
now was trying to speak to
[Music]
try to find out the author's name here
um
well stewart kaufman uh who is i think
he has become a little more active
recently i know they're pushing his book
origins of order really hard that's
something i read in like the 80s who's
going
this is a new one this is paul khan
okay
yeah okay k-a-h-n yeah k-h-n
and he's and he's basically trying to
use the argument that you can look at
the constitution or you can look at the
actual laws and and you hold up both
one is goal directed the project piece
whereas the other one is is is trying to
work from within and around
so that's it's that sort of between and
inside argument and that's not the same
as
as projecting yourself to a particular
outcome
yeah i can't i can't answer that right
now but i do want to tell a little quick
story uh when i was working as a senior
programmer analyst i was organizing this
project it was going to take a couple of
months
and my super is kind of looking over my
shoulder and i have the criteria and i
have a big flow chart and he says oh so
dave this is how you're going to do it
and i said i haven't decided he said
well wait a minute what's missing i mean
you've you've got the whole thing laid
out it looks like it ought to work and
says yeah i haven't decided i've only
done it one way there's no decisions
involved in that
i've just stated the requirements i
didn't decide how to do it so then he
went out and had a smoke
i ended up using a much better technique
that saved us a huge amount of rewrite
that nobody would have noticed because
they would have said oh yeah the answer
go for it
it's almost it's the zero to one which
we've talked about and it's also related
to
act
infer serve
infer you'll have something to infer
about
when you've acted whether getting that
first draft out or just doing a private
voice memo or
whatever stigma g you need you'll have
something interesting to infer if you
act i promise
and then maybe you'll be closer to
service than you expect
but infer
is still within the realm of like well
what would be sufficient to get the job
done
but if you go well what would be
necessary to do this one way
this is what would be necessary we could
um walk
from california to new york
that would be necessary for getting to
new york okay
it's gonna take too long i just don't
have that kind of time
what would be another way to do it
so there is a almost
a necessity and a sufficiency
in
action and inference
where action has a lot more to do
what's needed and
inference or thought maybe moves us more
towards thinking about
what's sufficient
not sure about that but also thanks for
sharing this um
this resource
well and back to what david was saying i
in the work that i was doing i often had
people who
who are very well versed in setting up
all kinds of sophisticated projects
asking me where's the project in this
and me having to jump up and down and
wave hands and say this isn't a project
that's why
we're doing it we don't know how it's
going to turn out until we do and then
we can look back on it and say well
did we minimize free energy we weren't
using minimizing free energy but
because i wasn't you know first in that
lexicon yet but that's essentially what
we
were doing
we wouldn't know until we'd arrived that
we'd arrived
and that's that's really uncomfortable
for people who were constantly saying
show me the milestones
okay well i can show you the stages
and i can show you how identity identity
is now in turning into identifying as
people are are constantly processing who
they are as they're
on board this
this
this idea but i can't tell you
what it's like because it's not
necessarily goal directed other than the
fact that we want to try to keep it open
as long as we can
and figure out what logic people are
using in order to be able to untangle
and
and pull things out of hats that that
others don't know how to do
so yeah
one other thing that makes me think
about is grants applications
so a grant application might frame
things in terms implicitly
or explicitly in terms of sufficiency if
you fund me we're going to
fix this disease like this is the grant
that will be sufficient for fixing this
disease
whereas saying that it's a necessary
step like we do need to understand how
protein one two three works
it'll be necessary but it's not the
whole picture it's not sufficient
so so much
when we really turn it over
is related to
necessity
because there's so many things that are
necessary
and so little
save for totally exhaustive examinations
of really contrived systems
so rarely do we find sufficiency because
if you can define sufficiency
you can make that bacteria in the test
tube de novo
and then life
it's kind of like puts a little twist on
it like what would be necessary and
sufficient for having a bacteria in a
test tube
putting a pre-existing bacteria in and
having it replicate
so life as this paper explores
it sort of threads the needle of
necessity and sufficiency
because the past
is necessary and sufficient for living
systems to be in the state that they're
in now
and so that's like the generalization as
well as the minute particulars
if anyone wants to ask a question
otherwise i think it's good to take a
second look at
the numerical example yes blue first
so just like
what got us to this point the past is
necessary but not sufficient but it just
just echoes the title like how did we
even get here right
yes
so let's look at that
bacteria and then of course we can jump
around
anywhere else
okay so the numerical example is of a
sensing
and feeling a sentient bacteria not
necessarily experiencing
and action isn't even in the loop here
but it's a sensing bacteria
and so
the organism
is inferring its prior beliefs about the
cause of the observations it makes
so it has a prior
let's just go over the um sort of
letters again so there's a class of
events for the organism so this is like
we need a special color or some metadata
tag like how can we tag map
and how can we tag territory let's just
use like
one set of colors or one font like map
comic sans
territory some
calligraphy script or something like
that
for the organism
of the organism now it's our map of the
organisms map
a and b
are events that are part of the class r
and so r is like the receptor state
and then
a and b
are inferred downstream of a chemical
signal
which is s so s is like for signal and s
is whether the actual molecule on the
outside is the a or the b
so this is kind of a discrete binary
choice
it's briefly discussed in the paper like
what happens if there's multiple
molecules or one could imagine that
what's being inferred is a continuous
variable like blood sugar
but alpha and beta
are s that's the outside stuff
and then a and b
are the organisms
receptor inference
blue
go ahead and then i i'll just both end
yeah so just to sort of
look at it in figure one or in the
formalism uh block that's in the paper
the organism has a prior and it's the
specification of priors
that differentiate
bayesian statistics versus frequentist
statistics
among a few other pieces but that's
really the key piece and so the prior
p of r
is 80 20 in favor of a
so
a priori
before how did you get there but a
priori it's 80
likely that it's a and 20 b before any
info comes in
then there's a likelihood mapping so
that's the the distribution of the
signal conditioned on the receptor state
so we're talking about what's the
probability of alpha
outside
conditioned on a and b and so it's 70
a and 30 for b
and vice versa
so what's interesting about this is
that's a pretty noisy signal
it's really only saying it's like if it
were 50 50 it'd be a useless signal
because it wouldn't
knowing it one way well it would also
depend a little bit on the frequency of
alpha and beta but
this is
a very noisy signal like 30 of the time
the receptor is giving the wrong
answer
so this is a way to show that with
multiple
uncertainties connected the right way
you can actually tighten your estimate
because in this example with the 80
prior on a
and then a 70
likelihood mapping
which is also a that's more like classic
active
jargon
after observing alpha
it turns out
that the estimate of a
the estimate of alpha
the estimate of state being a
conditioned on alpha being observed
tightens that prior
from 0.8 to 0.9
so
there's still a tightening of the prior
by a significant amount
even though
the mapping between the molecule and the
receptor state
is somewhat noisy
so that's like a bayesian bacteria it's
just applying bayes rule
to this
simple binary
outcome that it's doing inference on
blue any thoughts there
yeah so uh you know i this goes back to
something that dean brought up in the
dot zero like is oh and it's actually
something that axel wrote in the paper
like is the prior subjective or
objective
um and like the mis dysfunctional
requires and the survivability of
organisms with dysfunctional fires
so i just feel like i mean i know axel
says it's subjective but i feel like
it's nested so i feel like there's the
prior must be a subjective prior over
and objective frequency right like so so
if i frequently observe you know
sunshine outside when it's warm or
something like that like if mostly when
it's more when i feel warm i absorb
sunshine so when i have these two things
linked like based on that frequency i
then make a subjective assumption and
and that's how i feel that the the
structure of the prior um
kind of has to be
otherwise like it doesn't make sense to
put the math into the prior
um like like in my mind like if you
can't
if an objective prior is based on
frequencies but a subjective prior is
not a subjective priors
i guess but it's a guess over the
frequencies i don't know i feel like
there's like an extra layer that needs
to be tucked into the subjective prior
if you're gonna put math there
one
way that that's dealt with empirically
and then dean is what's called
parametric empirical base
and in parametric empirical bays you
kind of start with just
the prior being what you observed in the
past so if you had eight sunny days and
two rainy days
that's where that point eight and point
two prior comes from
so
it's um
not a way around specifying a prior it
just starts your prior in a place that's
empirically grounded
dean
yeah um
so i think in the point zero two i was i
was
trying to figure out how
the likelihood is really
the
the kind of background that we have
and that's what blue is kind of talking
to you and i was wondering about in
terms of context because if i see a
black dot on a on a white background i
think of period whereas if i see
a white dot and a
in a
in in black background with a whole
bunch of white dots i think how many
light years away is that concentration
of hydrogen right
so again we could d we could
decontextualize this
but
but if we do
d decontextualize and this is where it
gets really hard for me i get lost in
all of the terms but
if we do
decontextualize it
does that
does that help us in any way understand
both the subjective
and
objective factors in play that's all i'm
i'm wondering about and again
i get i get lost in the number of
different ways to be able to describe
this that's part of my problem i have an
upper limit on how much of this stuff i
can do once if you want me to focus on
days
i can do that that's hard enough for me
to concentrate on that
but if you actually think about this
okay so what does this actually imply in
terms of entailment
then it gets really really tricky
because i can't just focus on one thing
at once i gotta sort of think about what
all the implications of that are and
man can never go off in different
directions all at the same time so i
don't want to be too tangential here but
yeah that i i'm still not sure whether
the subjectivity in isolation can work
i'm not saying it can't i don't know
thanks dean blue then dave
so in like the empirical parametric base
that would be like an objective prior
like do you have subjectivity in
empirical parametric base because like
that's what axel was describing in the
paper you do you can have an objective
prior based on frequencies like it's 80
of the time you know sunny and 20 of the
time rainy and so you you get these
frequencies and that's what goes into
constructing an objective prior but but
when it comes to like an organism and a
choice or even like a scientist
conducting an experiment you know like
why would you even do the experiment in
the first place you have a guess right
like you have something that you think
will be the outcome and so like a
totally subjective prior is like well i
think
sixty percent of the time it's going to
be
blah blah blah and like that's a
completely subjective prior it's just
your best guess which which if you're
gonna try to really do objective
bayesian analysis
like you need to have a flat prior not
your best guess right you need to have
your prior needs to come from previous
observations and not you guessing but
but you could very well like not you
know do a very empirical or objective
bayesian analysis and just say my guess
is this and then you count make the
observations observe the frequencies you
know you go through the entire time step
and then at your next time step there is
that tightening between the likelihood
the previous likelihood and the prior so
that that is um
i mean as far as i understand it now i'm
definitely not an expert but so i think
like the subjectivity and objectivity
is
i don't know i think that there's some
some link there like i get it for
scientific bayesian data analysis like
you want to have a flat prior you want
to do objective analysis you want to use
you know the previous frequencies or
whatever but
i think that um you know in terms of a
mental calculation
it's also over frequencies or it's your
best guess like what do you think will
be the outcome and it's not always
doesn't always line up right
thanks blue dave
yeah um
the term
decontextualized i i kind of that
shocked me when professor jaron started
using that it's just he contextualized
what that that's just some some
jerk opens his mouth and blood he
contextualized his feelings at me and
you know if i want to know what's going
on i hyper contextualize i've been
particularly attentive to my own
prejudices and my own viewpoint you'll
think about what goes you know einstein
hated the word relativity he wanted to
come up with something like hyper
contextualized or the real world or the
the um
the tenser description uh
where you don't have to ask where are
you because you have the structure of
the world
um
what do people mean by by d contextual
odds uh is it is it a term of praise as
well as a term of contempt or have i
just always misunderstood
blue
so i love this term hyper contextualized
and
i i don't know that i would use it in
the way that you use it dave i i would
use it like
um
i would play out all of the potential
like what ifs like
like let's talk about counter factuals
can we can we put it into you know how
many different contexts will it fit um
and that's when when i think about hyper
contextualization it's like playing out
all the potential scenarios for me
thanks dean
yeah and building building on what blue
just said
um
so i i saw a youtube video where a guy
figured out a way to
make a target move so that no matter
where you threw the dart as long as you
were directing it towards the dart board
the target would create
the algorithm would create the target
moving so that you hit a bullseye every
time
and i was a phys ed teacher
i was like oh this is amazing and i took
it to one of my colleagues
who shall remain nameless and i said we
should show this video
to the kids and he was like why
and i said well think about it every
time a person moves their hands
to catch the ball
they're making the same kind of
adjustment and it was like a light went
off
a lot of the things that i was that i
was coaching were then decontextualized
and the proof was in the fact that when
you saw
something out of context that was
running the same parallel function
you didn't necessarily recognize it so
this was a really i i love hyper
contextualized
so i wonder if that's like abstraction
or
d
irrelevant contextualizing you take away
the irrelevant part of that
setting which is oh it's hands or some
other specific system
and then that
paradoxically
gets you to hyper contextualize because
it does
highlight the parts of the context
that matter dave
and there's that famous phrase from 1923
consciousness
of abstracting
training people to think scientifically
one of the first things you do is get
them really aware that they're how much
they're missing you're abstracting away
from at least 90 of whatever you're
looking at
uh and since i've got the mic um
there was the question of how a fielder
catches a baseball
a fly ball here it comes it's coming out
of the sky at you
and you know the good fielder knows how
to do that you ask him how you well i
just i just go to where the ball is
going to be
but he can't tell you how and there were
a bunch of people mathematicians and
programmers and physiologists
and philosophers trying to how in the
world are they doing this it looks like
they can't because we can't come up with
an algorithm that doesn't and they
finally
watch them
and i guess they got one one one guy
that's high on
whatever it is openness the big five
uh and and they says well what are you
doing how do you know that you're gonna
catch the ball oh i i know i'm gonna
catch the ball when i look at it and it
doesn't move
it doesn't move yeah it just hangs there
and i put up my my mitt and it since
it's i know where it's going it's going
to my mitt
and it's not moving and it's in my mid
and it didn't move then either
that's how they get there they figure
out what point in the field makes it
look like the ball's not going to move
as it comes toward there and that's
where you go
and then just
hangs in the field till it's in your mid
classic baseball physics
the thing i thought was have you ever
been high on openness
but then it's true there is a simple
algorithm like if you're looking and
it's to the left then you should go to
the left if you're looking it's to the
right and then you're
cool active baseball and anticipation
and the path of least action
blue
you want to talk about high on openness
i don't know that it reminds me of our
conversations with adam saffron right
and so
like what the psychedelic like
i would like to see like the psychedelic
like comparison with big five like the
integration of those two kind of things
in terms of active inference because i
do think that um the openness like
increases a lot under under the
psychedelic influence and so it's um
not have you been high on openness but
has being high ever made you more open
maybe is a different question
and well a few things there's sort of
the um rebus sevis albus relaxation of
beliefs under psychedelic strengthening
or just the altering of beliefs with
fristen carhar harris saffron
and what is being what priors are being
opened which priors are being tightened
and that was sort of at the heart of the
rebus versus cebus and then the sort of
um hegelian synthesis in albus and then
also in terms of how we got here
the first two weeks of january was live
stream number 13
with
adam
and colleague
on the cybernetic big five
and so that actually sort of started our
year
with thinking about how
frameworks that
a priori have nothing to do with actinf
or fep like big five was a principal
component analysis based
variance decom uh various partitioning
on psychometric data
yet
we saw how
active could help us
reimagine that
and generalize it
while also bringing action into the loop
so then it's kind of cool to see how the
personality traits come back into play
uh dave
and then we're going to return to base
and then we're going to move into the
variational free energy
well stop me if i already mentioned this
but um
there's been some
uh
criminological studies of the way
psychedelics are used by
as a recruiting tool of violent cults
you go to a rally
in favor i will not say whom
and if somebody seems like they're
really grooving and really into it you
give them a little ecstasy and that
locks them into the mentality
and if he's kind of getting fired up but
but he's not quite with it you take him
home give him some lsd and take him to
the session
and that moves him out of what he was in
and moves him into where he needs to be
in order to do the right things in life
maybe another a little bit of ecstasy
now and then over subsequent months to
just get him locked back in where he
needs to be just like
just like safran was saying you either
get him out of the of where he is or you
get him right back right deep into where
he is
well there's a long history of
people engaging in experiences taking
substances to move their
psychodynamics one way or the other um
i think
the active streams verge on it but we
also
remind people to be responsible and
legal
with their behavior and with the one and
only brain and mind that they have
let's return to the bayesian maths and
then see how that bayesian bacteria
moves into the variational free energy
bacteria
but i pulled out that one
quote from a um online statistics
resource so we can you know uh
the 0.0
is the frequentest bacteria
and so the frequentist
is basically looking at the outcome of
an experiment
you flip the coin ten times it comes up
seven heads and three
tails now that's not the most likely
possible outcome
for a fair coin but it's totally not an
unexpected outcome
so
in that case the frequencies can produce
a 95
confidence interval
given the variance granted by the sample
size
and say okay if if i get um within these
two numbers
um then i'm going to fail to reject the
hypothesis that it's fair if i'm outside
of those two numbers with my empirical
results i will reject at a given p-value
a given alpha
and so for the frequentist there's no
sense in asking about the probability
that the coin is fair it is either fair
or not fair so that's like accept the
hypothesis
implicitly because of the failure to
reject or reject the null hypothesis in
favor of a specified alternative
the frequentists make statements about
the probability of a sample after making
an assumption about the population
parameter which is just the kind of
average out approach average out value
of the probability of tossing a heads
the bayesian
in contrast
starts with information about coins
so specifies some distribution so it
could be like a bell curve
a gaussian centered at 0.5
it could be a super tight prior could be
a very loose prior and then the extreme
case of the gaussian with infinite
variance is the uniform distribution
and so that is like a flat across all
the possible values
that probability assessment of the heads
proportion is called the prior
probability each person might have their
individual assessment based on their
personal experience called a subjective
prior
alternatively a prior probability
distribution might be selected on good
properties of the resulting estimates
called an objective prior
i don't know if this is the only way to
use subjective and objective in the
bayesian context but this is just
an important difference between
frequentism and bayesian so
here is our bayesian bacteria
again it has some a matrix
that's mapping the signal conditioned on
the receptor state and then it has a
prior over those receptor states
that bayesian bacteria
then again it's a bayesian perceiving
bacteria we're not bringing action into
the loop yet but we're just assuming
like if you had the right estimate then
it would be easier to know what to do
correctly
um this is called exact base
because the exact numbers are plugged in
and then there's some exact number that
comes out and it's pretty much just
granted by bayes rule
what's the issue
well it's unclear whether living systems
have sufficient computational power to
accomplish that especially when there's
just massive
multivariate landscapes
so
what is the answer in the fep
well
instead of doing
exact base
there's what's called variational
bayesian inference
so here we're going to propose this
q
function
and the q function is going to be from a
family
that is specified a priori
and it is more easily fit
than just sort of the exact base
and then the way that we compare
is not by comparing at the end the
posterior likelihood
but rather we can compare
different
options
by comparing their
free energy
and this is how free energy is being
defined here
it's the negative
sum
over r those are the receptor states
a and b
of some q distribution
and then the natural log of the joint
distribution
of the states r and the signal alpha
multiplied
uh then
divided by qr
and so then in dot zero we explored a
little bit about how that's like the
recognition model that's like we're
going contingent on alpha and now we're
doing a hyper parameter estimate like
alpha we're going to a
and then what we're not going to be
exploring here is like a generative
model and then we talked about how those
map onto perception and action in the
world
so then the numerical example shows that
okay so the bayesian bacteria it did the
right thing it didn't go to that rally
that dave was telling it to go to
but we can also have a free energy
minimizing
creature bacterium
and we're going to see a case in which
the free energy minimization does the
right thing and we're going to see a
case where the free energy minimization
does the wrong thing
the difference between these two cases
is going to be the prior
that's set
and so that is the crux of the argument
that minimizing free energy is not
sufficient to be alive aka make the
right decisions
because both of these examples
are going to minimize free energy and
one of them is going to minimize free
energy in the right direction
and make the right choice because it had
appropriate priors a maladaptive priors
can minimize free energy but still
result in the wrong outcome
so in this case
we have the free energy calculation
for
um this
80 20
prior with a favor of a
and
contingent on observing alpha
the free energy of this is 0.47 which
doesn't have an interpretation as a
probability importantly
so that we're not within that zero to
one bounded space
and then
um in contrast
the representation of b
so that q r setting that to b
that has a free energy of 2.2
so free energy minimization
saves the day in that context
however it's not simply because the free
energy was minimized that the right
decision was reached here is a creature
with a prior on b of 0.8
and then
we see that
just barely
upon observing alpha
the free energy
of representing b after sensing a is
0.96 and the f when representing a after
sensing alpha is 1.094
so
the enzing posterior likelihood
is 63 percent in favor of b
and 37 in favor of a
so
we sort of
did move the needle towards
a
because we observed alpha
but our prior was so far off
that just one cycle of free energy
minimization still results in the wrong
outcome
that's the crux of the numerical example
provided in this paper
and the only point that it's being made
not this is how you'd model a bacteria
with the fep
the point it's making is free energy
minimization is not sufficient for life
dean
so daniel i got a question to ask so
i don't know because we're just talking
about sensing we're not talking about
you mentioned
doing but i is it is it is it doing or
is it directing so
because of the sample
sense
and because of what the
math
points to should we think of this kind
of analogous to a compass we're pointed
in the right direction we still haven't
actually acted or developed a feeling
from the sense yet we're just we're
still pre
doing we're we're we're orienting is
that
or am i
wrong
so if anyone else has a thought after
this so let's let's i think there's two
few aspects to this compass and
orienting approach
so
this little toy motif
about the recognition model
about having a prior
overstates in the world and then getting
some input
that could be plugged into an action
model
in a slightly more elaborate case so for
example as written in the caption for
figure one
more biologically realistic descriptions
of behavior require discussion of active
inference
they require it it's necessary and
sufficient you just have to do it
behavior is the result of a different
inference process that of an action
policy so pi
is not here in this bacteria
this involves more priors namely about
the transition between hidden states and
often about preferred sensory outcomes
so inactive inference with a partially
observable markov decision process we've
seen how there's like a matrix of the
transition frequency b
between the states at one time and the
states at the next time
and then policies are inferred
based upon which policies minimize free
energy
which ones are going to have the best
chance through time
of bringing states
into alignment with preference
the other thing that it made me think
about with the compass
is like the exact base
just
returns um a probability
and that is sort of like one compass
needle
uh
giving you just saying okay you're going
north by northwest or whatever it
happens to be this is your one estimate
you could be wildly off but given where
you were
and then just one blip of information
that's where your compass needle is now
pointing to
free energy it's almost like there's
two compass needles in this binary
choice
and then we're going to
select which one has a lower free energy
because we're looking the fact that this
is 0.478
f and this was 2.27
they don't have a natural interpretation
just like entropies you can talk about
the difference in entropy
but something having like
four
doesn't have an interpretation in the
world
and so it's kind of um maybe like
there's two different compass needles
and we're looking at the difference
between them or we're going to select
the one that has a lower free energy
dean
yeah i don't want to say that orienting
isn't a form of doing as well
it's just that what the what this shows
what this shows me is that like you
i you i cut out again but
when we're when we're trying to
when we're trying to determine
a and b
with a background
um we haven't taken an action step we
haven't developed a feeling yet
do we do we categorize that's
differently than if we were to look at
this through an active inference lens
where
we would then
push a policy forward right
so i'm not sure it is the orienting
fitting you fit into the policy piece or
is it pre-policy that's what i'm trying
to get clear in my mind
good
question
it makes me think about the uda observe
orient
decide act loop and about our
recent paper that connected active to
the uda stages
orienting
i think in this reduced example
the um the north pole north star
whatever it is is the prior
like that is what is oriented
relative to
so that's a purely recognition model
sense of orienting whereas in the
physical
realized world
orienting has
much to do with action and wayfinding
but this is sort of in the recognition
toy
there is still an orientation
of the prior
but i'm not 100 sure what do you think
dean
what i what i find interesting is is
that when i look at this
and i see a like a 0.8 and a 0.2 it's
very clear that we're somewhere between
0 and 1.
but when we're actually getting to that
wave finding space
and we're talking about entailment
one whole over two wholes
is different than two over one
so as soon as we move past one
into some of the more as you say
material
realities that we have to face down
that's when those actions
become
material like we can see what the
process ontology is but what
axel did was he brought the process
ontology down to it even
even closer to zero point because he was
using free energy
principle and he's talking about free
energy principle and bayesian stuff so
again sometimes
i have a general sense of this stuff and
i
just enough to get me into trouble and
be an insurgent and
and
point it people who are really really
smart and kind of go i think i know what
you're on to but it doesn't get me deep
enough to
to be able to write a parallel paper to
axles and sort of
either build them up or or tear them
down so
yeah i don't know i'm just that's why
i'm asking i don't know where oriente or
orienting
fits in this because i think it fits in
the zero to one space and i think it
fits into the one to three space
as we as the dimensionality blows out
that's back to the subjective
objective
crossing back and forth and again
i come off sounded like a complete idiot
here because there's somebody way
smarter than me who can blow my argument
up but at least i'm putting it out there
i'm showing up
oh you're you're
by being on a live stream and talking
about it you're like 80 of the way to
the paper
um
dave
is there something in this context that
would correspond to urgency
and i'm particularly thinking in
the terms that freud
was concentrating on when he talked
about how to get people to
be less neurotic he says
if you're
the the point that a person is in real
trouble as a neurotic is when the
dominant
factor in his life is reducing his
anxiety
and what we want to do is to get him to
tolerate his anxiety tolerate for
instance ambiguity not knowing is my
wife mad at me or not but don't get
crazy
sometimes you just can't do anything
about it
calm down tolerate the anxiety is there
something and i i'm just taking that as
a case of urgency urgency seems like
something that would fit into this
literature better
blue
so i just want to um like so i don't
know about urgency i'm going to kind of
derail off of that and more hook onto
this toleration of anxiety
or toleration of circumstances that are
not preferable for like a later more
preferable outcome
and so this is something that is taught
like i don't know in self-development
like a lot right like you have to put
yourself out of your comfort zone but i
mean also like
in like the meditative traditions like
to learning to like be with that
discomforting feeling and not like you
don't have to like get all upset and do
anything about it um so i i just wonder
if that fits like
it's a different different thing
different than urgency but what about
like where's the temporal
um
there has to be like a loop right like
uh i'm gonna tolerate this bad thing for
something that i think will be like a
more predictive outcome later like
how can i bathe that
that would be like an interesting
mathematical um
thing to try to work out
cool i added a uh slide
here here's the eisenhower matrix
so
um
the x-axis is urgent to not urgent and
then the y-axis is important to not
important so
one of the reasons why this is such a
useful and well-known tool is it
separates urgency from importance
because there's things that are urgent
like a chat message
that urge you to do something or they
have sort of a short time horizon but
then there's things that are important
or not important
and then
there's an orientation
when you're figuring out what is in
what quadrant kind of like the rumsfeld
matrix as well
and then that
has implications for action
so let's see
urgency and anxiety dave you mentioned i
don't know about the freudian urgency
concept much but it's of course with uh
psalms with fristen and the project for
scientific
psychiatry there's some clear links
there so it wouldn't be unexpected
and then
the idea that the imperative
is to reduce our uncertainty through
updating our model learning and through
action
so the reduction of anxiety is in
imperative
and then sometimes it crosses a
threshold towards being truly urgent
so it's kind of always in the background
but then other times it really is urgent
but it's always important
and then blue i
agree
delayed gratification
it's like
having the time horizon depth
to take the right policy selection today
so that your expected free energy
is higher in the future so it's like
would you rather have one dollar every
day
or
a thousand dollars in one year
depending on how badly you need the
money today and what you think you'll do
with it in the meantime and all these
other things
one person given their priors
might minimize free energy and come to
two different conclusions
and i think that's where we return to
this subjective versus objective
fep take
which is like
a person could
rationally evaluate
given their subjective priors and choose
to take that marshmallow
maybe that is just the waiting that they
have on their priors
or maybe somebody does the opposite and
that is just where their priors and that
stimuli
that's the action selection that they
take
and so
um
not sure how all these pieces tie
together
but
i think it
it
speaks to the
the the logic of action
and inference
and we want to have a logic of action
and inference or a framework for it
that is
broad enough to accommodate like making
bad decisions
if our action and inference framework is
only
tightly constrained scenarios that are
addressable
then it doesn't really help us as much
with real world scenarios
but it will be very cool to see how a
lot of these
daily
phenomena
connect
to the things that we're talking about
here
so let's see what else we had in the
pieces and and um also if if axel is
listening or wants to join for a dot 2
next week or for a future.3 i think
there's probably many things we could
ask and
what brought you to
write this paper and then
where do you go after this one
but pretty much the paper
delivers the
mic drop the coup de grace
with the free energy minimizing bacteria
which has bad priors
or let's just say maladaptive priors and
it minimizes free energy and makes the
wrong decisions so that's where that
section concludes
then there's a jump back to the more
philosophical framing
so although free energy minimization is
not sufficient for life
there might be an entailment relation
that goes the other way around
if you are alive it might very well be
because you did something like
minimizing free energy
that entailment relation is that which
corresponds to the weak version of the
life
free energy entailment relation so
remember way back when when we were
looking at the relationship between life
and minimizing free energy
this example has
decimated the strong claim blown out
make a youtube reaction video
um
but the weak claim is actually supported
because it seems like making adaptive
decisions
is consistent with free energy
minimization just like it would be with
making adaptive bayesian decisions
but we can say that it's not sufficient
to do so
and then the name of the section free
energy on a wing and a prior
so
yuck yuck yuck anyone can give a comment
on that but we just sort of
were reminded of two winged creatures
that we have talked about only a few
weeks ago in 32
there's the winged snowflake and then
the lepidoptera to a flame the moth to a
flame over here
and about how
in this snowflake example so go to 32 to
check it out in more detail
but it's like
the snowflakes with wings that act
adaptively
are going to persist and those are the
ones that are going to be
looking as if they've minimized
free energy in selecting the correct
action policies
whereas the ones that don't exist just
aren't if it makes bad decisions it's
going to fail to exist
um
so
it's an interesting
section
and it uses sort of evolutionary logic
in a little bit of a different way
because the evolutionary answer for
everything is just sort of like that's
what was favored by evolution
selection
uh
why does
this organ have this shape it's like
well that's what was selected on
and so that's just that's just why it is
that way even though we've talked about
tim bergen and other things we know
there's multiple y's
but here
we can now see the adaptivity of priors
instead of relative fitness
merely
blue as we know more information here
soon
but the the adaptivity of the priors
will be looking
as if it has been minimizing free energy
at the population level
so whether we frame natural selection as
increasing individuals with fitness or
increasing the mean fitness of the
population
but not necessarily the relative fitness
we can also do the same
but rather with a malthusian exponent
or
some other kind of
economic
fitness parameter we can think about it
in terms of the free energy minimization
dean
yeah i keep falling off here so i'm
gonna i'm gonna
have to get past all the hidden stuff
that you guys talked about when i wasn't
uh staying on on the broadcast but
what this points to me is interesting is
because
back to the previous slide you talked
about my fur
rip dean
please f in chat for dean
he'll rejoin in just a few seconds
sorry guys continue
yeah is it a wing my first question is
is it a wing as wing
and then second what but does it still
serve a function like could i use it to
fly
and so that's where the adaptive piece
actually comes in for me so again
there's two questions necessity and
sufficiency right and and you can even
see it in the representations is there
enough information in the representation
that i identify
as wing and then the second part of it
is
well then
i can see it can carry a moth or i can
see it can carry a snowflake that's the
function that it serves and so that to
me
again is the minimum of two and making
make sure that we don't
blend those two things up because it's
the fact that we hold both of them as
discrete and each serving a different
purpose that helps i'm gonna i'm gonna
jump off prematurely because i tired of
having to catch up and slow you guys
down but i'll watch the video and
seeing the point too thank you peace
dean
all right
okay
cool
so we walk through
much of the paper it's not a very
long paper
and it has just one core numerical
example again with a bayesian walk
through
and then two variational bays
one variational base that basically
recapitulates the first bayesian example
of an adaptive prior and then a second
counter example that provides a
maladaptive prior
that is connected to
evolution
and to the idea that we're only going to
see adaptive priors moving forward
because if that
model of recognition or that action
model is maladaptive
it will be seen less and less as time
goes on blue
so something that axel didn't mention in
the paper or maybe um didn't mention or
if i if he did mention it i didn't catch
it but
so the
adaptive priors always fit a certain
niche
right and so like that you're only
adaptive you know if you're like a
thermophilic bacteria right like you're
functional in a hot spring maybe not in
like an ice patch right so i think that
there's
you know if you if you take the
thermophilic bacteria out of the
hot environment and put it somewhere
cold then it's it's maladaptive its
priors are maladaptive but
only because it's just not fit to the
the correct niche environment and so i
think that there's this
you know the importance of of the niche
environment and also it makes me wonder
a lot in terms of evolutionary like
conceptually like
you know what if
it's always we always think about like
the best fit to the niche but but what
if it's like
the best generalist like is there like
the evolutionary i mean i guess that's
like the cockroach right like like the
evolutionary generalists that can go
anywhere be anywhere survive in any
niche survive on anything like is that
the best like how do how
how does that like
like a prior that fits no niche or fits
all niches how how does that like play
into this evolutionary paradigm i mean i
guess the cockroach will prevail
good question maybe this is related to
our discussion about context
uh having the prior of 80 20
and then we observed
um
[Music]
alpha but we could have flipped that if
it was all of a sudden dipped into the
beta ocean
then that prior
would be as wrong
as the maladaptive prior was in this
paper
so
whether or not it is adaptive as you
point out it is absolutely about the
statistical regularities of the niche
and that's the fitness of the model
fitness of the organism to
the
generative process is the generative
model
going to be fit to the generative
process and then generative processes
change things change out there in the
world
dave
yeah if the uh the work on my medics
going back to dawkins and the the
english lady that did
a lot more development of that notion uh
if that can be adapted to free energy
that will give a lot of very detailed
discussion of generation after
generation of the co-evolution of
adaptability and that
which is adapting
the the notion that the brain has been
adapted to imitate and to remember and
to pass on and to
recast concepts into many different
modalities
so do what blue was asking
yes
agreed with that
we can then just maybe look at the last
few pieces in the future directions
and then i think
see if we have any ideas for things to
discuss and point to and then other than
that just invite everybody who's
interested in listening
to join us for point two because we've
covered
much in point one in zero
so it's our last
journal discussion of 2021
come join
and
share how you got
here
and then what action selections you're
going to take in 22.
the last section is
free energy minimization as a historical
scientific principle
so that's a very fascinating idea
because
it's about anticipatory systems
yet it's a historical principle
that's where we get into the difference
between prediction and post-diction
postdictive scientific statements are
concerned with what must have been the
case instead of what will be the case
a statement such as the minimization of
free energy may be necessary if not
sufficient characteristic of
evolutionary systems which was from the
first and staff in 2007
is probably such a postdictive statement
and then axel claims that that statement
should be interpreted according to the
weak claim rather than according to the
strong claim
so interesting that even back then
the necessity insufficiency was being
used and arguably used properly
so then
what happened
how did
we get off the rails
or how did the strong claim come to be
and
the paper
i think
makes a powerful argument for the fep as
a postdictive model
but that doesn't mean that it can't be
used in an anticipatory way for
anticipatory systems moving forward
and
doing inference on the consequences of
our action which are also in the future
so how the uh
past and the present and the future
are linked
that's more of a dot too
how are the historical sciences
anticipatory sciences
and uh
i don't know is there now sciences
no that's what i call science 21
what else
would people like to discuss in dot one
blue
so
i would like to maybe get into more
about the living versus non-living and
maybe talk about um
you know this this idea of maintaining
structural integrity like is that a
quality of life or do things always
maintain structural integrity and like
does the fep apply when structural
integrity is maintained
and there's not life
i mean it's like i mean we talk about
like free energy minimization and
chemistry all the time like you form the
product that minimizes the free energy
and so i know that there's some
differences or some
a lot of extrapolation that has to be
done to get from thermodynamics to the
fep or
not extrapolation but like
it's retrofit
is maybe the right word um so i don't
know i would like to maybe see some of
that
where does the fep apply in situations
that are not animated is it
computationally is it relevant like when
we're talking about robotics
um
[Music]
yeah
that type of thing
yeah and is animate the same as sentient
like animate sentient
inanimate
not moving not animated
in sentient
like
can we just have an active model
that doesn't have any affordances or
where it only has one affordance
so it's still doing a recognition model
but then it's
policy selection is extremely
constrained
or like
so i mean i i don't even like to like
use life and non-life because there are
some things that like blur that boundary
also like it gets into like well what is
a virus is a virus alive like
uh and a virus is very exploitative like
it has dna like there's
some things some qualities of viruses
that make me feel like they're alive but
they're technically not
so
like what about if we just say dna
containing but then it's like it's this
test tube full of dna alive like i don't
know
it's hard
and so instead of even sentient
inanimate like alive and not alive
i don't know
yeah i i think the the the paper's
succinctness and clarity of argument
hides a big
question which is okay
so if it's alive
who told you that
so
if we can't go from
minimizing free energy to inferring
what's alive
then how did we get to here
right or what is even alive mean like i
don't think it's fully defined like if
we can't fully define death
like
i mean how do we fully define life right
so i don't know it's this there's this
big sticky
i don't know weird area i mean we kind
of instinctually know what is life and
what is
what is alive and what is not alive
um
anyway but the
i mean are the
crystals in bone alive
well they're part of a bigger system
that people usually don't have a problem
saying is alive but then why should what
people think matter
like
especially if we believe in evolution
and we think that our cognition is
oriented
not necessarily towards like ontological
realism
then why should it matter what one
percent or 99 or even 100 of people
agree upon
or even if we zoom like way out and get
super meta like how does life maintain
the structural integrity of life
that's an interesting one to think about
like like because i mean it's dependent
upon the niche environment which
includes many non-alive things like the
crystals that are inside of bone
um or inside the inner ear which help us
maintain balance right so there's all of
those things
yeah i think um
following with this quote
from the point of view
of the fep
the life cycle is that which corresponds
to the thing whose integrity is
maintained over evolutionary time
so then the ants nest architecture
is as much recapitulated as is the
casing of the larva
as is the larva itself
so
how will we define life i guess we can
just add that as a good you know just
sort of just something quick to hit at
the end of 32 or of 34.2 just you know
what is life and then um hash rodinger's
question been answered
i mean it's been a few years since 2018
and ram said it all
but has it been answered
what is life
um okay
so i think we will uh
conclude there
i hope if you're listening that you
would like to join us in the dot 2
where we'll talk a little more about
this paper and
how we got here and then where we're
going to go
in
22.
anything else dave or blue
okay thanks for the fun convo
talk to you all later